some call it a second front in the
ukrainian war the fight to control the
narrative while silenski has reached
audiences around the world with his
nightly speeches russia is also vying
for attention with a well-funded
propaganda campaign dw's head of
fact-checking josh aviva explains why
you should be careful when dealing with
images and information about this war
it's all just a fake
here ukrainian actors are supposedly
staging a russian attack on the civilian
population of ukraine
well at least that's what the russian
embassy in madrid claimed in a tweet
if the atrocities of the russian
military do not exist they must be
invented it says the video went viral
with more than 1.2 million views but
what does it really show
it is indeed a production but it's quite
different from what the russian embassy
purported it showed it's a film shoot
for the ukrainian war movie region of
heroes which is being shot in the kiev
suburb of hostimal
here you can see some pictures from the
set we found on social media the clip is
behind the scenes from the shoot as the
producer of the film confirmed to us
so there's nothing fake to see here but
a feature film and the russian embassy
tweet was deleted
russia's propaganda seeks to justify the
war and its consequences to the russian
audience by portraying the west as
inferior and lately we've seen a shift
towards new topics like the energy
crisis in europe and the sanctions
against russia
this report by russian state television
shows a food bank in germany whose
number of customers has doubled since
the war began
the report also claims that germans
linked the decline in their standard of
living to the sanctions against russia
however we found the original video from
the bavarian broadcasting service br
about the food bank in nuremberg it does
report on an increased demand as a
result of increased inflation due to the
war but not a single word about the
sanctions against russia
some things are only changed slightly
there or taken out of context others are
freely invented and are almost comical
like this claim from russian state
television
in the main news show the presenter
tells us that bacteria scabies mites
fleas and even lice are spreading in
europe right now because people don't
wash themselves anymore because of the
energy crisis and that europe is rolling
back to the middle ages as the anchor
says
neither at the national level or on
european level we could find even vague
evidence to support this wild claim
and the european center for disease
prevention and control ecdc confirmed to
us
there's no significant increase in such
infestations in the european union
probably the most remarkable
misstatement of this war however comes
from the russian president himself
the russian army does not strike at any
civilian objects he says
however this statement is in stark
contrast to reality
the massacres in butcher the bombing of
the maripole hospital
the use of cluster bombs and hakif and
so many more the list of attacks on
civilians in ukraine is long and the
case is well documented
in this case the facts contradict putin
nevertheless propaganda always almost
achieves one goal it sows doubt
it has been effective so far for russia
and as long as this war continues the
lies likely won't stop
you